[Music]
all right
so now it's time to go to hannah in
south
texas hannah how in the world are you
i'm doing well dr john how are you
i'm doing all right so i hear from kelly
that you have a
lot going on in your world just just a
bit
whoo man so i have
heard third hand secondhand i don't know
i'm
removed but you and i have never spoken
and um
you know that you're part of a special
episode today where um i know
enough or a little bit about some of the
details that i
i called a friend of mine and a former
mentor mind or a current mr mind who's a
renowned trauma psychologist who works
with um
traumatized kids and with autistic kids
and so
um that seemed to fit your situation so
walk me through what happened
um so uh
my my son is um he's been diagnosed with
high functioning autism and adhd
back in 2014. yeah so he was about
six we were uh my ex-husband and i were
stationed overseas
um and they didn't have the i guess the
ability
to to diagnose him so he was a little
late on being diagnosed
at about six or six and a half um
and you know we were working through
that my
ex-husband his dad and i divorced um we
separated in 2016
and the divorce was finalized in 2017.
his dad moved back to
his hometown and i moved back to mine so
there was a few hours
difference but in terms of the community
but he was he was a rock star so he was
not an ideal husband by any means
but he was a rock star dad um and we'd
gotten to a point where
we were back to being friends um his dad
would call me
if you know if he needed some help or
some
some suggestions or guidance or
just a sounding board
and i would call him because i'm like
hey this is what we're experiencing
with jb what are your thoughts on this
um y'all are co-parenting together
yeah absolutely and like i said we were
he was not an ideal husband but he was a
rock star dad
um and you know our our kiddo
just worshipped to the ground his dad
could do no wrong
um which is what kind of makes this
heart even harder
um so do me a favor do me a favor would
you take a big deep breath and
hold it for kind of one two and three
okay take a deep breath
hold it one two
three and let it out okay
all right so bring us to last weekend
um so i
was at work um so i got in a
his dad had called him his normal
routine was to call him
um at bedtime and they talked for about
20 to 30 minutes
um and jb came down he's like i get to
see my dad
and i was like oh nice of your dad let
me know but okay
um and so the next day
i was on the phone with one of my
girlfriends
kind of complaining about how he'd made
plans with our son but then
check to clear if we had anything going
on and that afternoon at work
i got a call from just to make things
easier
my mother-in-law so his dad's mom
and it was just like ripping a band-aid
off she's like um
you know he's dead and i was like
what do you mean and i'm thinking it's a
car accident or
something's maybe happened at work um
and she said that she'd just gotten off
the phone
with the detectives and he was dead
the girlfriend and and her child were
dead as well
they don't have all the details there's
an investigation
but the the the gun was was closest to
jb's dad um so
i called i've remarried and
i called my husband who is a police
officer
and you know he was on shift and i said
i just got this call i don't know what
to do
um and he said he you know i'm getting
off a shift at this
so i avoided going home like i was
i needed to get all of like process it
and try and figure it out
um my husband came home and i was like
i'm still not ready um
can you take him out for burgers you
know just give me time and the whole
time
they were gone i was googling how do you
tell your son you know that you're his
dad's bed or whatever
yeah yeah um were you alone at this time
no my so my boss i called my boss and my
boss was like you're not driving
i'm coming back and i'm going to take
you home my mom
my mom came to my house so she was with
me
um and it was still kind of one of those
um everything's in shock and i
remembered a few weeks back i'd listened
to an episode
where you had said get below the child's
eye level
um which isn't hard because my kid
powers over me anyway
but um i had him sit on the couch
and i got on the floor and i said i
talked to your grandma today
and your dad's dead and he was just like
what
no no no no no no and i was like and i'm
just sitting here and i'm
i'm choking up and holding back tears i
thought that i've had all afternoon to
rehearse this i've got this down this is
going to be
fine i can be clinical about it and it
it didn't work the minute he started
saying no
i i broke down um can i tell you can i
interrupt real quick
yeah i'm so glad it wasn't clinical
yeah a great gift you gave yourself and
your son was
a shared moment of humanity
and sometimes as parents we want to make
that band-aid we want to tear that thing
off
perfect in one one rip and
man um grief isn't like a band-aid
right and so i'm i'm actually relieved
that that happened that way
and that you all got to share that
however awful and
horrible that that moment will become a
stake in the ground for both of you all
to heal together and so i'm glad that
happened that way
um so you broke down and
i broke down um jb started asking
questions
um by this point there there had been
articles you know coming out and i was
starting to get
messages and phone calls and um i just
said
we don't know it was an accident that's
all i could
i i don't want to be the one to to take
that hero worship
away from him and
i unfortunately we were
we were good with it's an accident um
and then
one of the ways that jb kind of sell
food
is he plays music and and sings along to
the
to the lyrics so he had my phone and he
was doing
i guess karaoke pacing and stimming in
the backyard
and my mother god bless her sent an
article
that said confirms see sorry
and so you know of course when you post
a link it kind of
gives a little blurb and the headline
was
that and so you know he comes in and
he's like i thought you said this how
did it happen what and i was just
i was like i i don't have details buddy
um that article
i don't know what grandma's sending you
know and so i'm now trying to trap
between a rock and a hard place
of i've never lied to
our son um i've been
so long as age-appropriate conversation
so
i've been very forthcoming and
everything
but now i'm just like what do i what do
i do
how do i answer these questions how do i
field these questions what if somebody
at school says something
yeah i'm i'm also having to defend him
to
you know my family and my current
in-laws
because i'm getting the well it could
have been you
it could have been you and your son and
i'm like
if it couldn't have though like i mean i
would hope
not because while we were married
i mean he
he he loved with with such
such intensity and like
like he loved big but he also messed up
[ __ ] sure sure
oh um so so together
so bring me to right now what does um
have you just avoided these
conversations with your son
no um so when he asks questions
i i give him the answers that i have
okay so everything that's coming forward
right now
is is what's in the news
um the detectives are still doing their
thing they've got to do different tests
and
and all that stuff so it's still an open
investigation so until i have
until i have anything concrete i don't
want to answer questions
based on you know a local news article
i want to get my information from the
detectives
in my experience detectives
detectives will they'll say hey here's
where we're leaning
if you have those conversations they say
this is this is what it looks like
okay here's here's what i'm getting at
um there is the chance like so let's say
you're
you you hear that that set of facts and
one
set of like there's a part of you that
would dream maybe he was
murdered right maybe that something
happened to him or maybe he came to
protect
that little girl from this his crazy
girlfriend right
there's those kind of those things that
we dream about and then
the detective will say i mean it's we're
doing some forensics just because that's
what we do but
it's pretty clear that this is how this
played out right um
and what i don't want you to do is to
put off and put off and put off when
everyone around you
either believes they have a narrative or
is pretty sure that the narrative
they've got is
relatively right um and then the
neighborhood kid is the one who tells
your son
right does that make sense yeah as has
the
detective hinted one way this is what
this looks like
so the last update that
um and i'm getting the information from
you know his
his mom um the last update that they had
was um doorbell footage showed
um his dad coming in
to the the house um
and there were immediately shots fired
they did not anticipate that
they had time to defend themselves okay
so it definitely it definitely looks the
way
that the articles are presenting
yeah so what i'm going to tell you
is if because there's media out
um i would err on the side of telling my
son
here's what we at best best understand
at this moment
and not put that conversation off any
longer because what you don't want to do
is to plant any seeds at any point any
time
that mom's not going to tell me the
truth okay
and you mentioned something earlier that
i'm going to make sure you tattoo on
your heart
which is you will not be the one that
takes away his hero worship
that has already been done you will be
the person who volunteers to hold his
hand and walk through that pain with him
and being the person who talks to him
will not be in and communicates what
actually happened to him
is not the person who took that away
okay
hey that already has happened there's a
period at the end of that sentence
what you what you can do is one of two
things you can
continue to pull away from him
relationally
or you can lean all in and say i'm going
to walk with you however hard this is
and so there's a um big gap here that i
want to make sure you're processing
and i'm sure someone's told you this and
if they haven't
um it's okay to have your whole world
blown up
that your ex-husband has passed away you
can grieve him too even though you're
remarried and you love your new husband
and all that this guy's a part of you
you created life together you created
memories together y'all were overseas
together
it's okay to be devastated
yeah yeah and my husband has given me
that space i mean i've i've laid on his
chest
bawling my eyes out like and i and i
told him when i came home that day
i walked up to him and i said i need you
to understand i'm going to cry
i'm going to grieve i don't want you to
think that that means
that i i i love him
or miss him yeah yeah yeah i i didn't
want to
i wanted him to know that it wasn't out
of disrespect for him or our marriage or
the love that we have
but this was i was with him you know i
was with our son's dad
for a third of my life yeah he's a part
of you
he's part of that's right and he gave me
this perfectly imperfect child
and you know oh honey he's perfect baby
he's pr
he's perfect yes so um
and for everything and i've i've
put my husband through the ringer with
all of my you know
crazy trees and all that good jazz and
he's just he's also a rock star
and he leaves it and good for you good
for him what a stud
he went through um i had a a box of
memories and keepsakes from my marriage
that were all of the photos
family photos and whatnot um and letters
from his dad from when he was deployed
and
um you know in all the different
trainings and whatnot that he'd written
to
jb that i i kept to make sure that he
would have those and when he turned 18 i
was going to say here you go or when he
was old enough to really
understand them i was going to hand them
over um
so when that night when we were
explaining it you know i went
out took him out to the garage and i
pulled everything out and we just had
letters and pictures and memorabilia
just kind of thrown all over the place
so he could see it
and um my husband
took some of those pictures and he
brought him upstairs in his room and
he's like where do you want him
and he started putting pictures of his
dad and family photos and stuff
in his room because he's like your dad's
always going to be there
we love you we're here for you and we'll
give you the answers
as we get them awesome wow that's you're
in a pretty remarkable place and so um
and as a part of this call um
i think kelly lets you know i met with
um
a mentor of mine like i said is an
expert in this and so
you'll be able to go back and we'll send
you a recording of
his his recommendations um he's
infinitely more brilliant than me i tend
to he's a very
uh he's an exacto knife and i tend to be
a little bit of a sledgehammer
um but a couple of things to keep in
mind as you
move forward one is um
less is more be very clear your daddy
died
and he died by suicide best we know is
your daddy died by suicide
are you doing okay and that silence that
weight
of just saying that with a period at the
end of it
do you know what suicide means let your
son tell you back
what he understands about that dig into
that
um dr gomez told a story about an
eight-year-old saying
yeah that means that they killed himself
he said yeah
anything else and then the child
responded with yeah that means now
they're burning in hell
right and it was whoa let's stop right
there so we're going to have that
discussion right so
get let him speak to it and you also
know the things that
um your son uses so it may be that
you're going to play some music the
music that suits him
um a number of of
young folks with autism have very
particular
self-soothing behaviors right and it may
be that you set that up for him and let
him know hey we're gonna have a hard
conversation about
um we got some information about your
daddy i'm going to pass along to you
okay always checking in do you feel safe
now
you are safe right now nobody's going to
hurt you not not here
letting him know that he's okay now and
then moving to what i think will be the
hardest
the next hardest part here is um
and we don't know why but it appears
that
daddy killed your friend too and letting
that have appeared at the end of it
and that might ultimately be we're going
to write a letter to dad
and we don't have answers to those
questions he didn't leave a note we
don't know why
we know that he really really loved you
and we know that he
was not well that he was really not well
at the end of this
at the end of his life and these these
moments are scary
and they are heartbreaking but i'm here
your stepdad's here
and we are going to rally around you and
this will be a really difficult season
for your family but i want you
your son to see you hurting too because
that's going to make him feel less crazy
okay give him permission to ask you
questions whenever they pop
up and they're going to come up at
really weird inopportune times
right i would strongly recommend
dr gomez the he was one of the
founders of the tfcbt trauma focus
cognitive behavioral therapy
there are some great practitioners in
texas and i would look for one in your
local area
or online tfcbt is this is the acronym
for it
and they will walk you through a very
stepwise program
you do this then we do this and then we
do this and we teach
young people behaviors on how to process
and feel that trauma
and i want you to make sure you're
getting the help you need through this
whole area
this whole season if somebody calls you
and says well that could have been
say we are done with this conversation
and if this continues i'm gonna hang up
on you
because it didn't and we're moving on is
that
you hear me there draw a firm boundary
there nobody's gonna be planting these
what if garbage seeds in your mind that
doesn't benefit anybody
that's somebody else's drama that
they're not going to bring to your house
right um two or three years from now
you may exhale to and look at your
current husband and say
that could have been us y'all can deal
with that later that's not a for right
now
right um and then most importantly is
this
i want you and um again whether it's
writing a letter drawing a picture i
want you and your son to
communicate a vision of where your
husband is now
and often when a kid experiences
somebody
adulthood too who's passed away
traumatically
we still remember them in the car wreck
in that moment of pain with the the shot
in their body and that rattles around
our hearts and minds and our souls and
there's something therapeutic about
doing the exercise of where is he now he
was hurting so bad he was sick he was
struggling so bad he died by suicide
but right now he's at peace right now
he's quiet and he's still he's not
hurting anymore
and there's something cathartic about
that and the big what if existential
questions
is he in heaven is he in hell that's
going to be for you and
the your particular faith leaders to to
walk through together
why why why did he do this why do this
that's gonna be between you and a
professional therapist there's not gonna
be a lot of great answers to that
but i will tell you this um dr gomez
said this and i'll reiterate it
the fact that you have already met with
him
and already done the hard thing to say
your daddy died
um was so hard and it was such an olive
branch of trust to your
son you get to share that moment with
him to your
new husband um your son's really really
lucky to have you hannah
it's really really lucky to have you and
i want you
to i want to thank you for blessing all
of us
very very very few of us will experience
what you experienced it's trauma on top
of trauma on top of trauma
and it's getting up in the news and your
son's going to get harassed about it at
school
it's a big thing it's one of those
before and after moments for you and
your family and community
most of us won't experience that but all
of us
will experience hard conversations with
our kids all of us will experience
awkward grief when an old girlfriend or
an ex-husband dies
we don't know how to navigate that all
of us will be faced with
gut-wrenching conversations we don't
know what's next and i want to thank you
for being brave
and honest and open with us and letting
us walk alongside you during this
for those listening man it's been a
heavy one there's been a heavy one
and i want to hark him back to circle
back to the beginning
um with dr gomez um
i got two phds like
hundreds not thousands of people i've
walked through hard conversations with
heart series
i've i've done these death notifications
i've gone
into a house into houses similar
to what um hannah's ex-husband
was involved with i may have been there
and even then
when you're dealing with the pain or the
hurt or the discomfort or strong emotion
of somebody else
i want to make sure i'm right i want to
make sure that i've crossed all my t's
and dotted all my eyes
and so i don't care how much schooling
you have how much experience you have
true professionals stop
and pause and call somebody
true professionals true people of
character and dignity
circle back and say hey i just want to
make sure i'm right on this deal
and i'm not saying i get it right all
the time i don't i know i screw up all
the time and i try to be honest when i
mess
it up but we live in a culture now we
live in a world now
where everybody's so quick to throw an
opinion on a fire everyone's so quick to
judge and to say it's because of this or
you did it because of that
and i just want to give you a glimpse of
behind closed doors that's not the way
most people that i know act
most practitioners call another
practitioner say i'm about to have a
hard conversation with a hurting mom
i need to make sure i'm walking through
this thing the right way or i've got
expertise on trauma i've got expertise
on
meeting with hurting families but i
don't have expertise in
hurting families with a young person
with autism how do i do that one
right walk me through things i need to
know about that or somebody who's got
cancer or somebody who
um i i know what i strongly believe
about this political statement
but i haven't had this conversation with
someone who believes this way and so
walk me through what this person might
be feeling or experiencing
what i want everyone to do is slow down
in our lives
just slow down be a little more humble a
little
slower to judge a little a little
quicker to be curious
a little quicker to ask one or two more
questions a little
slower to judge to shame to say oh i
know this one i know this one
i've been that guy man and you know what
you do you hurt people
with our kids ah that didn't hurt you're
fine maybe it did hurt
with our spouse we should do it like
this right where now she has to choose
between fighting me
or just going along with it right we're
so quick so quick so quick
i hope today's episode has given us all
one
moment of exhale
we're gonna hug our loved ones a little
bit tighter today
we're gonna bridge that gap between
those we love today because it's not
worth it man you never know
and two will be a little slower to judge
a little a little quicker to reach out
and make sure we're on the right path i
don't care if you've done
something 100 times a thousand times one
more phone call doesn't hurt
you're going to be okay being wrong you
can be really gentle with people who are
hurting
and right now all of us all of us are
hurting
let's be a little slower and a little
gentler